Ja gestern ist leider nix mehr geworden, aber ich hab's ja vorgestern gesagt, gestern
morgen muss ich mit meinem Nachbar was am Haus angucken, also nicht an UNSERM Haus, an
denen im Haus angucken, weil die wollen was dranbauen und dann müssen wir zustimmen.
Und ich hab mal zugestimmt.
Und da ist mir wieder was aufgefallen, was wir für geile Richtlinien in Deutschland
haben und zwar, ähm, ich hab keine Ahnung wie das heißt, aber es ist wirklich hochgradig
omega null, nämlich, also, wenn man was anbauen möchte an seinem Haus und da muss man ja Pläne
vorlegen, was ist das links oben, keqwe, was, äh, das sind einfach 30 Sachen übereinander.
Genau, also da brauchen wir eine Genehmigung, wenn man was bauen will, selbst wenn man was
an seinem eigenen Haus bauen will, da brauchen wir eine Genehmigung.
So, und je nachdem wie die Lage ist, müssen die Nachbarn auch zustimmen.
Kloks HD, 10 Monate, dankeschön, excellent subscription.
So, und da gibt's ne geile Regelung und zwar, ähm, wenn man an der Grenze zum Nachbar baut,
dann wird ausgerechnet, wie groß der Schattenwurf ist des neuen Gebäudes auf das Grundstück
des Nachbars und das dann quasi als Fläche genommen, muss man Gebühren bezahlen.
Es ist nicht so, dass die Gebühren der Nachbar bekommt, sondern die muss man am Bau, muss
man beim Bauamt bezahlen, ohne, ohne irgendwie, dass der Nachbar was von hat, also wo der Sinn
davon liegt, leuchtet mir nicht wirklich ein, aber exzellent Vorschriften haben wir in Deutschland.
Nee, es hat er mir gestern erzählt, der muss jetzt irgendwie 3000 Euro bezahlen, weil seine
neue Wand quasi irgendwie ein paar Meter Schatten dann, oder nicht mal, auf, auf unserem
Gebäude, auf unserem, unserem Hof wirft, dort wo eigentlich nur die Garage ist, da
muss er 3000 Euro für bezahlen.
Also, wenn das sein Nachbar bekommen würde, würde ich sagen, okay, das macht irgendwie
Sinn, weil, dann überlegt man sich das zweimal, aber der Nachbar bekommt ja davon nichts.
Da ist ja auch ein Bedarf für Schallschutz berechnet, ja, ist das, können wir uns gleich
schon angucken.
Ja, und das hat gestern nicht funktioniert, ich war erst um, ob 11.30 Uhr oder so fertig
mit dem, und da wäre aufwachen Stream zu spät gewesen, und dann habe ich gestern lieber
noch ein bisschen Passive Exile gegrindet, und heute habe ich eigentlich auch keine Zeit,
aber ich habe gedacht, komm, jetzt ist 22.20 Uhr, bisschen, bisschen Stream müssen wir
noch machen.
Was soll denn der Chat sonst machen, ne, ohne Stream?
Solaranlage ist klar, die Solaranlage, die habe ich ja nicht im Hof stehen, dort wo man
mit dem Auto lang fährt, das macht eigentlich überhaupt nichts, also dort wo der Schatten
hinfällt, ist eben eine Garage, oder unsere Garage, ist total sinnlos eigentlich.
Aber schön, dass das Amt dafür Geld bekommt, habe ich ja kein Problem mit, ich muss es
ja nicht bezahlen, ne?
Der Karlsson, 10 Monate, Dankeschön, und der Kommentator auch am Start, Nilsit auch
am Start, das kriege ich jetzt hier Schlag auf, forgets auch, haja ja, so viele Subscribers,
das ist ja fast schon, jetzt muss ich das Emote finden, das ist ja fast schon.
Mal gucken, ob man das kombinieren kann.
Das hört sich bescheuern an, ja, ich habe ein neues Emote hinzugefügt bei BenatwitchTV
oder FFZ, mal gucken wer es zuerst findet, ich finde es selbst gerade nicht, aber es
müsste da sein, wer findet es zuerst?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, da, der Kommentator hat es, der Kommentator hat es gefunden,
der Scamtrain, zfchris, underscore, 2 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub, huge, brauner Marok,
4 Monate, jetzt geht es aber Schlag auf Schlag hier, vielleicht soll ich öfters mal irgendwelche
Streams ausfallen lassen, da gibt es mehr Subs, so, also, oh, jetzt, jetzt, ok, oh, das
ist ein nicer Soundtrack, das Scam war ein echt nicer Soundtrack, oh, ich muss mal mein
Pepega-Tool anmachen, sonst übersehe ich Fragen im Chat, ist das Stream-Tool an, nein,
das mache ich jetzt gleich, erstmal muss ich meinen Desktop wieder aufräumen, also aufräumen,
also, ne, kleiner machen, nicht aufräumen, iLow1706, 4 Monate am Start, Dankeschön,
excellent Subscription, huge, User 1, 2, 3, 6, 9, 8, 7, 4, 5, ich denke fast, dann hast
du den Passwort copy-pasted beim Anmelden, für 3 Monate, Dankeschön für die Subs jetzt,
aber der IQ steigt wieder, der war jetzt ein bisschen runter die letzten Tage, aber jetzt
gehts wieder aufwärts, ich finde die Präsentation vom ersten iPhone echt nice, ja, die kenne
ich, die ist nice, ja, der Scam-Train ist schon bei Level 3, Alter, der Jebait-Train, Abo-Falle,
Abo-Falle Incoming, ich mache mal kurz den Chat hier auf, das war auch hier was, wenn
ich was erzähle, was sagen kann, also, wo warst du gestern, habe ich doch erklärt schon
im Stream, ist Stream4M kostenlos, was, Musik zu laut, ja, das liegt an dem Game, das ist
zu laut, guck, ansonsten überhaupt kein Problem, der Soundtrack von dem Game ist zu laut, kann
man das wegmachen, ich will den Scam-Train weghaben, ne, ne, wenn ihr Subbt hilft, also
ich finde es gut, dass ihr Subbt, aber Atomfeed Stufe 1, Dankeschön, Excellent Subscription,
aber der ist ja nicht fertig, der kommt jetzt in eine neue Stufe, oder, oder ist der jetzt
fertig, ich wollte den gerade auspländen, Level 3 Complete, ne, da geht das wieder von
vorne los, wisst ihr, Leute, nicht Subben, ich plände den jetzt aus, also ihr könnt
gerne Subben, aber nicht um den Subtrain voll zu machen, so, wie kann man den auspländen
hier, FFZ, Train, Parents, Ha, Bam, da ist er weg, der Hype-Train, Hype-Train Deleted,
der Mast, weg ist, also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, kennst du gute Hoster, wo Dedicated
Server mit kleinen GPUs anbieten, ich finde eine Hoster welche, ne, ich glaube, das ist
eine gute Frage, keine Ahnung, ich hab noch nie nach einem Hoster gesucht, das ist echt
eine gute Frage, ich hab noch nie nach einem Hoster gesucht, der GPU Computing Ressourcen
irgendwie anbietet, hatte ich bis jetzt absolut noch keinen Bedarf, keine Ahnung, es ist aber
echt eine gute Frage, vielleicht weiß der Chat ja was, ist die VMSoftware, die du benutzt,
kostenlos, ne, das ist VMS Workstation, das kostet was, was kostet das aktuell, die haben
an Weihnachten immer Angebote, da kostet das nur 69 Euro oder so, News, Shopping, ne, das
ist zu teuer, also an Weihnachten kriegst du es eben für 69 Euro und natürlich gibt's
auch andere Ressourcen, die ich hier allerdings nicht bewerben möchte und auch natürlich
nicht dazu rate, die zu verwenden, ist genauso kostenlos wie Winrar, ne, Winrar kannst du
ja wirklich verwenden, ohne dass du es kaufen musst, vor allem bei Workstation kannst du
nicht verwenden, es sei denn, du suchst dir irgendwo eine Seriennummer raus, was wie gesagt,
da kann ich jetzt ja keine Werbung für machen, ja, also was ist das für nervige, ah, irgendeine
Mario Kart Musik, die geht mir auf den Keks, ja, das ist doch viel angenehmer, so, ähm,
warum ist das nur so kurz, ach ne, das sind 10 Stunden, das versteh ich, so, was hab ich
jetzt übersehen, Musik zu laut hatten wir, das hatten wir schon, also wie gesagt, Anbieter
kenn ich da, kenn ich da wirklich keinen, die von Hetzner, echt gibt's das, Hetzner
GPU Server, ah, man braucht das, in der Hetzner Cloud braucht man das, das, die Abrechnung
ist doof, ich mein 111 Euro, aber wenn man nochmal was kurzes braucht, äh, wir gucken
mal, Digital Ocean GPU, haben die GPU, GPU Instances, ok, was haben die da, ach ne, das
ist ne, ne, haben die nicht, ist echt ne gute Frage, es wundert mich, dass es das nicht
gibt, weil ich mein, ganz ehrlich, ne, ne, ne Hetzner Server für 111 Euro im Monat,
würde ich mir jetzt nicht unbedingt kaufen wollen, die meisten Leute brauchen das ja
nur ganz kurzzeitig, ich glaub bei Asher gibt's sowas, Azure, wie gesagt, ich glaub Asher
hat sowas, also wie gesagt, das ist ne Frage, wo es mich jetzt wundert, dass es da keine
einfache Antwort drauf gibt, ganz schlecht, easy, der Hype Train war erfolgreich, tja,
wir gucken, ob die Buu Lake Musik jetzt vorbei ist, ah, besser, ja der Livestream, der macht
irgendwie, der normalisiert die Musik irgendwie nicht, nö, auf eine SSD packen, auf ne Micro
SD Karte wird das immer relativ langsam sein, man darf nicht vergessen, der Raspberry Pi
ist weder das Prozessor Wunder irgendwie, aber die Micro SD Karte dürfte eher das Problem
sein, für eine Nextcloud Instance für einen User gleichzeitig reicht ein Raspberry Pi
locker, aber halt auf der Micro SD Karte ist das ziemlich langsam meistens, ja Sebaro,
das kann man sicherlich machen, aber da werd ich jetzt hier keine Färbung für machen,
naja, so, was haben wir denn für schöne Videos, ok, die seltenen Sachen im Universum, Zufälligkeitsvergleich
oder Wahrscheinlichkeitsvergleich, what the fuck, ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich das aufgemacht
hab, das wurde mir vorhin empfohlen und das sah in der Vorschau interessant aus, das ist
bestimmt voll an die Haare herbeigezogen, ok, 1 in 1, wie, was ist 1 in 1, what, 1 in
3, achso, 1 in 8, oh, Pepofet, das ist doch im Leben nicht mal 1 in 8, ok, vielleicht
auf die Weltbevölkerung, weil es in Afrika immer noch genug Leute gibt, die unsere Ernährung
verhungern, aber auf Firstworld Geschichten ist das nicht mal 1 in 8, da ist das wahrscheinlich
eher 1 in 3 oder sowas, guckt aus dem Fenster oder geht über den Hauptbahnhof, da ist jeder
zweite fett, ach, 1 in 10 auch noch, never, äh, also, ja, über die Weltbevölkerung mit
Sicherheit, aber nicht hier in der normalen Industrie, Firstworld, sonst was Ländern,
garantiert nicht, ja, ok, Kokona, was, achso, und Abschluss machen, ok, Standardabweichung,
alles klar, getting engaged, ok, 1 in 2, das stimmt, das ist ziemlich gefallen, dass die
Leute heiraten, ja, kann ich mir vorstellen, 1 in 2, 67 immer noch zu viel, Zwillinge, ok,
ja, Zwillinge sind gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich, ähm, die anderen Varianten sind aber deutlich
unwahrscheinlicher, Max Streamschauen und Kreise kreiten, beste Idee, oh, sterben an
einem ermordet zu werden, 1 in 249, Moment, 4% äh, das erscheint mir jetzt ein bisschen
viel, nein, 0,4, ja, man müsste das ja nochmal, nochmal mal 100 nehmen, oder, oder man könnte,
man könnte wahrscheinlich auch sagen 100 durch, ne, ne, ne, Schwachsinn, 1, warte mal,
warte mal, warte mal, nein, nein, nein, 1 zu das sind 0,04%, 0,004%, nicht 4%, 1 von
2 sind 50%, egal, ich will jetzt keinen, keinen Big Brain machen, es, also ich glaube, ich
glaube in Wirklichkeit sind es eigentlich 0,85, 7, 3, 1, Quickmuffs, warte mal, also
1,1, 1 von 2 sind 50%, so, dann sind 1 zu 4 sind 25%, 1 zu 8, 12,5, ja doch, oh, Big,
Big Brain, Alter, das könnte man auch anders sagen, 1, genau, 1 zu, 1 zu 20 wären dann
5, oder, tatsächlich 0,4%, wo war man denn jetzt hier, 0,4, ok, also, also 0,4%, warum
ist das so, warum ist das so viel, das ist ja, das ist ja mehr als die meisten Krankheiten
wahrscheinlich, aber ok, das sind, das sind, das sind NA Zahlen, alles klar, ja, das ist,
ok, Kokona schlägt, schlägt zu, dadurch, dass ich letztens den Emote gelöscht habe,
ich weiß noch nicht mal, wo ich mein Kokona Emote habe, nein, 0,04, excellent, es ist,
es ist, aber höher als ich gedacht habe, Quickmuffs, 1, in was, ein Ei mit zwei Eigeln,
in Gelb, ok, ist das so, es ist auf jeden Fall wenig, echt ist das, Moment, die Chance
ermordet zu werden, na gut, es gibt halt auch viele, es gibt auch viele Klebblätter, aber
trotzdem, also, die Chance ermordet zu werden ist viel, viel höher, ich meine, 4-plättriges
Klebband hat die wahrscheinlich jeder schon mal irgendwann, irgendwo gefunden, aber es
werden halt auch nicht so viele Leute ermordet jetzt, aber trotzdem, also, aber Kokona Zahlen,
damit haben sie es eher, Dating ist Supermodel, ok, wie haben die das errechnet, also, wie
haben die das errechnet, haben die gesagt, es gibt 88.000 Supermodels, oder was, und
die Chance, und ich bin einer, dass ich die Date ist 1 zu 88, nee, nee, das müsste ja
dann viel mehr sein, hä, wie haben sie denn das ausgerechnet, das ist, G-Bait, was das,
ja, äh, Dings, ähm, Siamese, sowas, Siamese Zwilling oder sowas, ja, Royal Flush Poker,
da müssen wir jetzt mal Isle of Cookies fragen, wie das, ob das wieder so ist, ja, 1 in 1.740.000,
also, dass man da unten irgendwo ist, oder wie, was, ein was, ein was, ein Art Savant,
was ist das überhaupt, was ist ein Art Savant, ist das sowas wie Fotografisches Gedächtnis
oder was, ok, ich weiß nicht, was das ist, was ist ein Art Savant, wie man das ausspricht,
was ist ein, ok, das ist eine Krankheit, Autismus, manchmal auch nach, äh, Schlaganfall, und
Krämpfen und so, ok, das wird dann, ok, das sind Leute mit Low IQ, das kann ja schon mal
der Chat nicht sein, der Chat ist ja nachweislich High IQ auf Twitch immer, also, da wird ja,
da wird ja nie jemand was anderes behaupten wollen, dass der Twitch Chat, gerade wenn
man mal bei XQC oder sowas reinguckt, da ist der Chat ja nur wirklich absolut Massive IQ,
oder Pokimane Chat, ist auch, IQ ist da komplett durch die Decke, äh, Virgin Check PokiW, finding
a Multicolor Lobster, das ist kein Krebs, keine Krabbe, Lungus, was ist ein, Lobster
war noch mal ein, ein Hummer, ein Hummer, genau, exellent, Powerball Jackpot, ja deswegen
spiele ich auch kein Lotto, bei Lotto spielen ist er eh out, heute spielt man Slots auf
Twitch, was, was hat denn der Raspberry Pi damit zu tun, 1 in 2 Milliarden, das ist fast
wie der Michael 50 Billionen hier, 1 zu 50 Billionen, ne, ne, der Michael 50 Billionen
ist ja gar nicht 50 Billionen, der ist ja glaube ich nur 500 Millionen eigentlich, so,
ähm, was ist denn das, was ist denn ein RPE, Deficiency, Eliminato 5 Monate, Dankeschön,
Only 3 Patients, au, au, au, nur 3 Fälle in 27 Jahren, das ist die seltenste Krankheit
der Welt, ok, aha, gut zu wissen, falls man es mal kriegt, ne, die Chancen sind aber doch
echt gering, you, wie ich, ich oder der Twitch Chat, jetzt wirds aber philosophisch, ja,
die Chat, wir sinds, das ist ja, jeder ist es ey, alle zusammen, Kollektiv Big Brain,
in englischsprachigen Chats hätten sie jetzt alle gespammt, I made this, no me, das ist
auch so ein unglaublich dumme Kopf wie pasta, wo ich keine Ahnung wo das herkommt und irgendwie
finden es alle lustig und ich finde es dumm, so, hier sind wir, Chat, und wir sind noch
nicht mal bei der Hälfte angekommen, you, schon wieder ich, oh, ah, ja, dass ich rausgekommen
bin am Ende, ok, ja, oder, oder wir, ein, einer von uns, excellent, was, was ist das,
voll marks in MCQ-Test, ah, dass man, dass man, äh, die Prüfung besteht, wenn man mal
einfach, was, ja, ich glaub menschliche Gehirne sind da nicht so gut drinne Sachen random
zu guessen, ich hab letztens auf Reddit was gelesen, da hat einer vorgeschlagen, eine
random generator, äh, Methode für das menschliche Gehirn, ich hab es aber leider schon wieder
vergessen wie es funktioniert, es war gar nicht so kompliziert, das war eigentlich richtig
gut, jetzt konnte man mit ein bisschen Kopf rechnen, also Leute die zum Beispiel ausrechnen
können ungefähr wie viel 1 in 249 ist, ähm, da konnte man im Kopf random nummer, also
Pseudo random numbers im Kopf generieren, zwar jetzt nicht wirklich so richtig gute,
aber einfach genug, dass man es im Kopf machen kann, und wenn man sich mal überlegt, das
ist gar nicht so schlecht sich mal so eine Methode zu merken, wenn dann irgendjemand
verarschen will, ähm, oder, oder wenn mal irgendwie einer sagt, ah Max lass mal einen
Trick probieren, random schlägt keiner, es gibt so viele Videos auf YouTube wo dann irgendwie
der krasse Mentalist am Start ist und sagt, wir spielen jetzt irgendwas und, ähm, was
die Leute halt können ist, die können ja, die können ja, no shit, ich weiß, die können
ja nicht wirklich in die Zukunft gucken, ähm, die haben einfach die Erfahrung, dass die
wissen was am wahrscheinlichsten ist was die Leute so sagen, und wie kann man die Leute
insoweit beeinflussen, dass sie das sagen was man halt im Vorfeld schon prediktet was
sie sagen, und wenn man dann im Kopf, stellt euch mal vor jemand probiert das bei euch,
und ihr habt einen random generator, äh, Algorithmus im Kopf, den man einfach im Kopf berechnen
kann, der hat keine Chance der Typ, der ist einfach lost, der ist einfach, der ist, der
wird einfach komplett daneben liegen, wer das ein paar mal macht, klar wenn man immer nur
einen Test macht, dann ist es die, dann kann er trotzdem mal richtig liegen, aber ich hab
vergessen wie es funktioniert, es war gar nicht so schwer, also ich weiß nicht was der
MCQ-Test ist, das ist bestimmt irgendein Kokona-Ding, oder ist das ein IQ-Test, Triple 3x, Moment,
was, äh, ach, select, 27 Zeiten in der, ach, dass man 27 mal in Folge das Auto rauskriegt,
okay, da gibt es ja auch diese, da gibt es ja auch diese, diese, ähm, weiß nicht ob
ihr das kennt, ja, das ist ja auch so ähnlich, mit den, mit den Türen und der Ziege, ja
genau, das ist glaube ich das gleiche, ja, und da ist der Trick, dass der einen fragt,
ob man seine Wahl ändert und ich glaube, mit, mit Switchen hat man eine höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit
zu gewinnen, also sprich, wenn einen der Showmaster fragt, möchte man doch eine andere Tür nehmen,
muss man immer sagen, man nimmt eine andere Tür, dass zuerst gewählt wird, genau, ein
Drittel Chance gewinnst du und beim zweiten hast du zwei Drittel, und das liegt einfach
daran, weil du immer eine Tür gezeigt kriegst, in der halt, das, ne, wie geht das nochmal,
du kriegst immer eine Tür geöffnet, wo eine Ziege drin ist, ne, du kriegst immer eine
Tür geöffnet, wo die Ziege drin ist, und ich krieg's nicht mehr ganz zusammen, aber
wenn man sich das aufmalt, genau, genau, hier, wenn man sich das aufmalt, dann sieht man,
dass man hier quasi viermal die Chance hat zu gewinnen, ne, zweimal die Chance hat zu
verlieren, das heißt, man hat zwei Drittel Chancen zu gewinnen, ein Drittel, ups, ein
Drittel nur zu verlieren, wenn man, wenn man, äh, swappt, das ist auch so was, wo man sieht,
dass man im Hirn nicht so gut mit, ähm, Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung und random Sachen ist, aber dann ist das,
das hier, nur, dass man 27 mal richtig liegt, hintereinander, was, tot, bei, was, space,
ist das Müll, Müll im Weltall, ach, das ist, dass einem Müll aus dem Weltall auf den Kopf
fällt, no one have, have been killed by falling space junk before us, okay, frage mich, wie
sie das ausgerechnet haben, Weltraumschrott, ne, mal ganz davon abgesehen, man könnte ja
auch sagen, okay, wenn irgendwelche Meteoriten einschlagen oder so, das ist zwar kein Weltraumschrott,
kommt aber auch aus dem Weltall, das kommt ab und zu mal vor, dass da Leute verletzt werden,
zwar selten, aber das kommt ab und zu mal vor, so, ein 10-stelliges Passwort zu raten,
ja, das ist schon recht unwahrscheinlich, allerdings, da sieht man mal wieder, es ist
sehr unwahrscheinlich, ein Passwort zu erraten, allerdings, mit der heutigen Rechenleistung
ist es nicht so sehr das Problem, Passwörter auszuprobieren, je nachdem, wie viele Sachen
man verwendet, und generell kann man sagen, Länge ist besser als, ähm, unterschiedliche
Nummern, äh, als unterschiedliche Zeichen, also wenn man die Auswahl hat, zwischen einem,
ich sag jetzt einfach mal 20-stelligen Passwort, oder, ähm, gar ein 8-stelliges Passwort,
dafür hat das 20-stellige Passwort nur kleine Buchstaben, und das andere hat groß und kleine
Buchstaben und Zahlen, dann ist das mit 20, mit 20, ähm, Stellen um ein viel viel vielfacheres
besser als das 10-stellige, weil es ist ja immer quasi Anzahl der möglichen Zeichen,
Hochlänge, und da siehst du, eine Länge mehr, ist schon um ein Vielfaches mehr Möglichkeiten,
als wenn du unten die Basis quasi änderst, ne, nicht Basis, wie heißt das, wie nennt
man nochmal den Zahl, also, ne, bei Exponent, ja, ist das Ding nochmal, war das, war das,
war das nicht Basis, doch Basis, ne, ja, Basis, excellent, quick maths heute, ja, 1 in, juh,
schon wieder, ja, ja, mit dem Unterschied, dass sich die Frage ja nicht stellt, weil,
wenn wir nicht hier wären, könnte man uns jetzt halt auch gerne Gedanken machen, das
ist genauso wie die Frage, mit denen sie sich auch schon lange beschäftigt haben, warum
ist die Erde genauso weit weg von der Sonne, was gibt es da, woran liegt das, und die Frage
ist eigentlich falsch gestellt, ähm, wir sind nur da und können uns Gedanken drüber
machen, weil wir die richtige Entfernung haben, also man darf, also wenn man umgedreht
rangeht, so nach dem Motto, wir sind da, machen uns Gedanken, warum sind wir genau so weit
weg, ist eigentlich genau falsch rum, und ist in dem Fall auch so, ähm, es hat halt
uns getroffen und deswegen sind wir da, andersrum wären wir gar nicht da, excellent, cracking
SHA-1-encryption, ok, da sieht man schon mal, und, und, und, äh, hash, also cracking ist
ja eh das falsche Wort, ähm, damit ist gemeint, man findet einen Input zum, also einen doppelten,
einen doppelten Input, also man findet einen Input, der zum Hashwert passt, und, äh, theoretisch
gesehen gibt es unendlich viele Inputs, die den gleichen Hashwert erzeugen, die Sache
ist nur die, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, welche zu finden, ist nicht sonderlich hoch, es
gibt unendlich viele, ja, aber, das brauchst ne Weile, bis du einen gefunden hast, es ist
ja logisch, dass es unendlich viele Klartext-Inputs, die du hashst, geben musst, die den gleichen
Hashwert ergeben, weil, wenn man aus nem, aus ner beliebig großen Menge Input einen
immer gleichen, gleich langen, ähm, Hash generiert, muss es ja Kollisionen geben, also
früher oder später muss der gleiche Input, äh, muss unterschiedlicher Input mal zum
gleichen Resultat führen, ist ja logisch, man macht ja aus viel wenig, also bleibt nicht
aus, dass es da, äh, Kollisionen gibt, allerdings paar Schar 1 ist halt die Chance so ne Kollision
zu finden doch ziemlich gering, und, ähm, oder es dauert halt lange, und paar Schar
256 noch mal ne ganze Ecke weniger, und das meiste ist ja dein Schar 256 heute, das ist
übrigens auch so oder so ähnlich, die Art und Weise, wie euer Passwort hoffentlich,
hoffentlich, ja, ich weiß, da kommt noch ein bisschen was dazu, ähm, aber wie euer
Passwort hoffentlich bei eurem, äh, E-Mail-Anbieter, Twitch, YouTube, was auch immer hinterlegt
ist, zwar nicht im Klartext, schon, sondern, äh, mindestens mal das hier, besser als Schar
256, oder, äh, Schar 512, genau, ja, so, und dazu kommt, dass man meistens das ganze
noch mit nem Salt dazu speichert, ähm, weil das verhindert, jetzt müssen wir mal eine
Runde Big Brain Talk machen, weil das verhindert, dass du Sachen im Vorfeld berechnen kannst.
Also, wenn wir jetzt mal von ausgehen, wir nehmen mal einen relativ schlechten, äh, Hash-Algorithmus
aus der heute, also, der heute noch ein bisschen verbreitet, sind wir bei MD5, so, MD5 hat
bei weitem nicht so diesen Pool an Möglichkeiten, der rauskommen kann, aber immer noch ganz
schön viele, also immer noch zu viele, dass man das einfach effizient durchprobieren
kann. Wenn man allerdings jetzt das Passwort, den Passwort Hash einfach nur MD5 Hash summt
oder Schar 1 Hash summt und speichert und das mit allen Passwörtern gleichmacht, dann
kann sich ja jemand die Arbeit machen und einfach ganz, ganz viele Sachen im Vorfeld
schon berechnen und dann können wir relativ schnell gucken, ok, wir haben folgendes Hash-Resultat,
welcher Inputtext passt denn dazu? Das ist das, was unter Rainbow Table läuft. So, und,
ähm, wenn du dann quasi noch eine, einen Sold dabei speicherst, das ist quasi ein fester
Wert, der im Klartext mit dem Passwort Hash gespeichert wird, dann ist es total einfach,
wenn man, äh, die, ähm, wenn der Anbieter das Passwort überprüfen will für ihn, da
rechnet er einfach den Sold mit dabei und gut ist. Allerdings, dadurch, dass da ein Random
Sold mit dabei ist, führt es dazu, dass du jegliche vorberechnete Tabellen wegschmeißen
kannst, weil es hat jetzt sicherlich nicht jeder auch mit jedem Sold Tabellen berechnet.
Dafür würde keine Speicherplatz der Welt ausreichen. Big, ich, genug Big Brain Talk,
ich mach mal weiter. Aber heute ist mal wieder, äh, Exzellent. Huge Brain. Allerdings 1
zu 249 konnten wir nicht ausrechnen. Jatzzebaro, plus dass mein Passwort wahrscheinlich anders
aussehen wird als Hech. MeKoopa ist ganz neu hier. Schön, dass du am Start bist. Big,
Big Brain Chat ist angesagt heute. Ah ne, gar nicht Subscriber, einfach nur so. Ja trotzdem,
dass du am Start bist. Verguckt, ähm, auch Klimaanlage. Können wir die Klimaanlage
kurz anmachen. Die Musik wird immer intensiver, so als passiert jetzt irgendwas Schlimmes.
Perfekt N-C-A-A Bracket. Was ist denn das? Das ist Kokona Zeugs, oder? Ach, das ist
eh, Football. Nee, Basketball. Äh, ach, das ist so ein Ding, wie, wie was man beispielsweise
bei der WM macht, wo man im Vorfeld redet, was für Ergebnisse die einzelnen Spiele
haben und welche Mannschaften weiterkommen. Ja. Bingo, in 24 Moves. Also, da bist du,
wenn du eine EA-Präsentation anguckst, schneller dabei. Allerdings nur bei Bullshit-Bingo,
nicht mit Zahlen. EA-Präsentation, richtiges Bingo Board, da hast du nach 5 Minuten Instant-Bingo,
sofort. Gar kein Problem. Sudoku-Peer. Oh, dass das gleiche Sudoku zweimal generiert
wird. Ganz einfach, ich druck's einfach zweimal aus. Finding Asta, was? The rarest natural
occurring element. Was ist Asta-tine? Wie heißt das auf Deutsch? What the fuck? Gibt's
das auch auf Deutsch? Asta-t. Ist ein radioaktives chemisches... Aha. Okay. Gut zu wissen. Ist
das seltener als ein YouTube-Video von dir? Naja, da kannst du noch ein paar, also für
ein YouTube-Video musst du noch ein paar Null dranhängen. Ist das... Wie wurde das
entdeckt? Ich glaube, das hat Knossi immer aus einer Slotmaschine gezogen. Tracking
MD5-Encryption. Warum ist MD5-Encryption? Warum ist die... Ach so Cracking, nicht eine
Kollision-Fit... Nee, Moment. Warum ist das... Warum hat er da... Warum ist Char1 schlechter
als Char1? Entire Poker-Table obtains... Moment, das geht doch überhaupt nicht, oder? Das
geht doch überhaupt nicht, da reichen doch die Karten gar nicht für. Ach so. Assuming
each player gets 5 cards from a new deck. Okay. Wollte ich gerade sagen, weil das geht doch
gar nicht. Ah so, okay. Dass man 2 gleich gemischte Decks bekommt. Ja. Ja gut, die Chance
besteht ja. Wo man halt wieder dabei ist. Also das menschliche Gehirn ist halt schlecht,
was Wahrscheinlichkeiten angeht. Es ist zum Beispiel nicht unmöglich, dass wenn ich jetzt
einen Kartendeck nehme und schmeiße das mal gegen die Wand, sammle das wieder ein und
schmeiße es nochmal gegen die Wand, dass es dann wieder so sortiert ist wie am Anfang.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist da, aber es ist halt recht unwahrscheinlich. Moment, was?
Minecraft? Perfekt Chicken Chocke... Chocke. Was ist das? Ähm, das scheint sehr unwahrscheinlich
zu sein, aber ich hab keine Ahnung, was ein Chicken Chocke ist. Okay, was auch immer.
Ein Luftzeug. Pokémon Encounter. Single-Portein-Format. Also jetzt werden die Wahrscheinlichkeiten,
die gehen jetzt aber von wenigstens noch ausschreibbar zu bisschen vielen Nullen. Ach nur 2173 Nullen,
das ist ja nichts. Jackpot for life. Okay, also 80 Jahre am Stück im Lotto-Gewinn. Ja,
dass das ja unwahrscheinlich ist, kann man sich glaube vorstellen. Um nicht zu sagen,
ist das nicht unwahrscheinlicher. Okay, da kommt ja noch ein bisschen was. Ja, da hab
ich auch letztens ein Video zugesehen. Es gibt ein paar ganz gute Quick-Muffs-Videos
auf YouTube. Da hat es auch einer letztens als Vergleich genommen, dass wenn ein Affe
einfach nur random lang genug auf der Schreibmaschine tippt, dass er irgendwann auch mal Hamlet
schreibt. Aber es dauert halt. Von 100 Sekunden Physik kann sogar sein, ja. Jo, schon wieder
uns. Ja, auch nicht. Okay, jetzt müssen sie sich aber schon krass was aus den Fingern
saugen, so langsam aber sicher, oder? Kannst du mal YEP enden? Nee, YEP ist ein kacke
Mode. Sucked. YEP. YEP cock. Every birth in... Ah, okay, ja. Klingt auch sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Warum male? Warum male? Es könnte genauso gut female sein. Was soll das hier schon wieder?
Ist das hier mal wieder, mal wieder hier systematischer Sexismus schon wieder hier auf YouTube? Satt.
Was ist satt? Irgendwas Kokonamäßiges. Amiabi, aha. Okay, jetzt saugen sie sich echt krass
aus den Fingern, Alter. Powerball-Checkpot, sowas haben wir hier gar nicht. Correctly guessing
all Gmail's password, oder was? Ja, okay, das kann man wenigstens, das kann man wenigstens
halbwegs ausrechnen. Na gut, ein paar Annahmen musst du schon treffen, aber trotzdem. Genau,
Passwort Länge. Und es gibt eine Milliarde Passwörter. Was reitet die Amis eigentlich,
anstatt Milliarde Billion zu sagen? Das verwirrt einfach nur alle. Okay, jetzt, jetzt. Okay,
ich weiß, ich gesse mal, was noch dran kommt. Es gibt nämlich eine Sache, das habe ich letztens
in irgendeinem, was war denn das? Ich glaube Urknall Weltall und das Leben, ich weiß nicht,
ob ihr den YouTube-Channel kennt. Ich glaube, ich habe es ja letztens in einem Video gesehen,
dass es irgendwie Theorien drüber gibt, wie lange es dauert, dass sich quasi aus zufälligen
Anordnungen von unterschiedlichen Teilchen im Universum, dass es gerade zu einem Zeitpunkt
irgendwann irgendwo im Universum zufälligerweise alle Teilchen sich so anordnen wie in einem
menschlichen Gehirn. Und dann hast du quasi mal ganz kurz ein menschliches Gehirn mitten
im Universum. Was es dann auch immer denkt. Und das dauert lange. Mal gucken, ob das noch
dran kommt. Das ist, das ist 15 Head. Every deck's on earth, cards on earth. Okay, ich
meine, das Video könnte ich auch machen. Die nehmen einfach die ersten Beispiele und machen
noch was unwahrscheinliches dran und rechnen das aus. You quantum teleporting. Aha. Das
halte ich für ein Gerücht, dass das funktioniert. Auch mit dieser Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht.
Ah, das meine ich übrigens. Das meine ich übrigens. Das ist das, was die letztens auch
in einem Video erzählt haben. Genau. Es ist ein Gehirn, genau, was irgendwo im Universum
entsteht, wenn halt lang genug Zeit vergeht und sich zufälligerweise irgendwann mal innerhalb
von was weiß ich, wie vielen Billionen, Trillionen, Billionen, sonst was Jahren, mal alles so zusammenfügt
wie es in einem menschlichen Gehirn ist. Tja. Wir werden es nicht miterleben. Es ist die,
äh, äh, Serious Max, die Frage ist, wann kriegen wir raus, wann Doktor Disrespect
gebannt wurde? Naja, okay. Wenn wir in einer Simulationsleben, ja, da gibt es ja auch genug
Leute, die Theorien darüber anstellen, ob wir nicht, ähm, in einer Simulation leben.
Übrigens, by the way, muss ich doch mal sagen, Matrix 1 ist nach wie vor immer noch einer
der besten Filme überhaupt. Ja.
Okay. Da am Schluss haben sie sich schon hardcore was aus den Fingern gesorgt. So, was haben
wir sonst noch für schöne Sachen zu bieten?
If you miss Call of Duty from, äh, if you miss YouTube from 2010, then watch this. Naja,
das watchen wir jetzt nicht. USP 45 No Chopper Gunner Nuke Challenge. Zehn Mythen über das
Darknet. Intel sagt, das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren. Der Lego Hey Bale Rapper.
Was zum, das drei Minuten, das gucken wir uns jetzt an. Ich find das so geil, was die
Typen da bauen. Jetzt hat er schon hier mit Green Screen, es wird immer, es wird immer,
ist heute Sonntag, ja, quasi, quasi. Das ist so Big Brain, das Zeug, was der baut. Darf
man Videos schicken? Ja, aber wir haben nicht mal so viel Zeit, noch eine Stunde oder so.
Kannst ruhig mal schicken. Aber ich hab ne Vorschau, also ich guck immer vorher, was
geschickt wird. Ich mach das nicht einfach so auf. Wie gut das funktioniert. Okay, wie
hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er das überlebt, den ganzen Garten lang zu, das
sollten die mal ausrechnen. Wie hoch die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, dass er das überlebt, wenn er den ganzen
Garten hier rollt. Der geht garantiert kaputt vorher. Warum bauen wir unsere Infrastruktur
eigentlich komplett aus Lego? Ich wollte schon immer in Lego DSL Modem. Das ist richtig
advanced. Übrigens Heuballen wickelt man nicht in Folie, das ist bestimmt recycelbares
Papier. Aber so funktioniert ein Heuballen-Wickler nicht. Ist das so? Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie
ein Heuballen-Wickler funktioniert. Wird das ein Mega? Nein, das ist ein Heuballen. Vape
Nation hat schon ein bisschen was. Wie hat er das jetzt abgekriegt? Okay, der Chat sagt,
so funktioniert ein Heuballen-Wickler nicht. Das heißt, Twitch Chat hat das jetzt quasi
klassifiziert als Low-Brain, Low-IQ-Lego-Konstruktion, weil der echte Heuballen-Wickler nicht so
funktioniert, oder wie? Oh, guck euch das mal an. Ich mein, dass das funktioniert, ist
schon cool. Das geht fast als Klopapier durch, wenn man es nicht besser wüsste. Das ist
übrigens Klopapier. Das ist kein Plastik, das ist Klopapier. Klopapier von AliExpress.
Übrigens, die Masken von AliExpress sind da. Das ging sehr schnell. Ich hab doch, ich hab
doch Corona, also nicht Corona, Atemschutzmasken von AliExpress bestellt. Die sind mittlerweile
schon da. Wann hat man das bestellt, Chat? Vor einem Monat? Das ging ziemlich schnell.
Welche denn? Oh, das weiß ich nicht mal. Mal gucken, ob wir es hier noch im Warenkorb
oder so drin haben. Ne. Weiß ich nicht mehr. Welche? Die Dinger sehen alle gleich aus.
Jetzt, wo Corona fast vorbei ist, ja mal gucken, ob das fast vorbei ist. Aktuell schieben
diese Panik von wegen zweite Welle. Ich persönlich hoffe ja, dass es noch eine Weile dauern wird.
Universum, 3D, Größenvergleich. Ah, das kenne ich, das kenne ich. Das fand ich an sich
so spannend, 5 Minuten lang. Also ich hätte jetzt kein Problem, wenn Corona noch eine
geile ganze Weile dauert, weil solange Corona ist, kann ich Homeoffice machen. Aber selbst
wenn Corona vorbei ist und keine Homeoffice-Sachen mehr gehen, da werde ich meinen Chef fragen,
wie das aussieht mit Homeoffice-Vertrag. Also ich will nicht 100% Homeoffice machen in Zukunft,
aber ich weiß, dass bei uns schon einige einen neuen Vertrag haben mit festen Homeoffice-Tagen,
sowas will ich auch haben. Oder muss nicht unbedingt feste Tage sein, aber mit geregelten
Homeoffice-Tagen, weil das ist so viel angenehmer, wenn man einfach mal einen Tag noch nicht
mit der Bahn oder zwei Tage je nachdem nicht mit der Bahn fahren muss. Ja, und das ist
für, ich sage es dir immer, das ist für alle Beteiligten in dem Fall besser. Das ist für
mich besser, mir tut der Rücken nicht weh, ich kann ein bisschen länger ausschauen, ich
bin fitter, ich mache unterm Strich auch mehr, ja, ich kann besser nachdenken über Sachen,
ich habe meine Ruhe bei einigen, also es ist für alle Beteiligten einfach besser. Ja,
man spart Geld natürlich, man spart auch Zeit, vor allem spart man halt auch Nerven, weil
wie sehr fuckt das einen teilweise ab, wenn irgendwie unterwegs was nicht glatt läuft,
weil man will ja eigentlich heim. Mich persönlich nerven die anderen Leute, die ich halt tagtäglich,
die mir da auf dem Weg begegnen, die gehen mir halt auf den Sack und da ist mir das, ja
gut, wenn man bei der Lufthansa arbeitet, kann ich verstehen, ganz ehrlich, wir könnten
auch Corona abschaffen und trotzdem Homeoffice beibehalten, also ich brauche das Corona, Corona
will ich nicht haben, aber Homeoffice. Tja. So, ähm, solange nicht mehr über die Bahn
geradet, richtig, ja. Top Battlefield Plays, oh, da hätte ich jetzt mal Bock drauf. Das
Video, oh ja, das wollte ich mir mit euch angucken, das ist echt gut, wer bei ihm noch
nicht auf dem Channel gewesen ist, der macht wirklich gute Videos, ähm, es gibt international
ein paar Channels, die Videos in die Richtung machen, allerdings deutschsprachig finde
ich nicht, sonderlich viele, die sich erstens im Gaming Bereich gut auskennen, äh, auch
selbst schon Sachen gemacht haben und auch wirklich interessante Themen besprechen,
wo man so gar nicht drauf gekommen wäre oder halt auch bekannte Themen noch mal, äh, im
Detail, also den kann ich echt nur empfehlen, ich gucke mir da fast jedes Video an, außer
jetzt Mario Maker, ähm, lohnt sich echt zu abonnieren. Was ist das, gucken wir uns mal
an, das ist wirklich ein gutes Video und der Titel hat nichts mit dem zu tun, um was es
im Video geht, kann ich gleich schon sagen, ja, ähm, es geht um was ganz, was anderes,
woran nie jemand denkt und ich wundere mich, warum ich mir da noch nie Gedanken drüber
gemacht habe.
Dieses Video ist gesponsert von dem Zuseher Torxon, da er so viel gespindet hat im letzten
Twitch Stream, kommt das Video sehr viel früher als eigentlich geplant. Torxon, Poggers, exzellent
Torxon.
Ich weiß, dass einige im Titel des Videos lesen werden und sich direkt aufmachen in
den Kommentaren etwas zu schreiben, aber ich verspreche euch, dass es nicht darum geht,
an was man zuerst denken würde.
Denn es geht nicht um Killerspiele, um Shooter oder sonst etwas, was unfähige Politiker
nutzen als Sündenbock, um ihre eigene Inkompetenz zu vertuschen. Nein, dieser Kanal ist teilweise
auf die Videospielentwicklung ausgelegt und genau darum soll es heute gehen.
Als Sinnweis, ich werde diverse Clips verwenden aus Spielen mit brutalen Szenen, habe aber
den Text so angepasst, dass man ihn auch verstehen kann, ohne die Bebilderung. Bedeutet, wenn
ihr empfindet, ihr seid für sowas, dann könnt ihr das Video einfach im Hintergrund
aufspielen.
Monka Toss.
Also um was gehts? Splatterfilme sind so eine seltsame Sache, bei der wir uns als Menschen
freuen, wenn ekelhafte brutale Sachen passieren. Kopf abhacken, Magen aufreißen, Gliedmaßen
abtrennen, all das ist im Film komplett normal.
Ich gucke ehrlich gesagt keinerlei Splatterfilme, ich finde das zum größten einfach ultra
langweilig. Manche gucken das wegen dem Schockfaktor oder sonst was, ich finde es zum größten
einfach nur zum einschlafen.
Ich gucke eh kaum Filme.
Ich bin hin und wieder amüsiert von solchen Filmen, da sie komplett übertrieben sind
und man häufig merkt, wie versucht wird, es so umzusetzen, dass es nicht so langweilig
aussieht, auch wenn es natürlich alles andere als realistisch ist. Aber warum langweile
ich euch mit Filmen? Nun Videospiele haben ein Problem mit dieser Form von Gewalterstellung,
denn anders als bei Filmen muss man nicht tricksen. Es wird nicht überlegt, wie können
wir das faken? Weil du durch Killerspiele abgestumpft bist. Wahrscheinlich ja, weil man
halt sagen muss, bei Spielen ist was komplett anderes als bei Filmen. Filme finde ich einfach
nur langweilig. Damit ich mir einen Film angucke, muss der irgendeinen gewissen Unterhaltungswert
bringen und pure künstliche übertriebene Gewalt ist nichts, was mich da großartig unterhält
bei einem Film. Je nachdem, wie es gemacht ist und ob es da, wenn das ein Film ist, der
aus anderen Gründen sehenswert ist und Gewaltinhalte hat, dann ist das was anderes. Aber rein
Splatter um zu splattern finde ich langweilig. Schockt mich auch nicht wirklich. Also da
gibt es mittlerweile im Internet viel, viel ekligere Sachen, die man sich angucken kann,
wenn man will, die wirklich schocken. Und mittlerweile bin ich ja auch so auf dem Stand,
dass ich viele Sachen gar nicht mehr aufmache, von denen ich weiß, dass es eklig ist. Ich
habe es ja im letzten Film schon gesagt, früher habe ich fast alles immer aufgemacht. Links,
die jemand geschickt hat, Videos, wenn irgendwer gesagt hat, oh ich muss mal gucken, alle möglichen
Links. Und heute mache ich so, wenn ich einen Link bekomme, Link sehe oder was auch immer,
dann, ich habe schon so einen Vorschauplugin, da gehst du über den Link und da zeigt dir
schon den Titel von der Seite. Ich mache manche Sachen absichtlich nicht auf. Ich muss mir
nicht das fünfte Video angucken, wo einem der Kopf wegfliegt, so nach dem Motto. Irgendwann
ist es auch mal gut. Und der Unterschied ist, wenn das irgendwelche Videos von echten Leuten
sind, da wird es einem teilweise schon ein bisschen übel. Im Vergleich zum Film ist
das vollkommen egal. Also das letzte Mal, wo ich mir gesagt habe, das muss ich mir nicht
mehr geben, war folgendes, ist schon ewig her, da hat mir mal einer ein Video geschickt,
also auch einen, den ich kenne, das waren auch Zeiten, wo man sich ab und zu irgendwelche
Videos, da hat man sich auch den Assi Tony geschickt oder sowas, als, nee Insomniac
tut, was anderes. Und einen Video geschickt, das habe ich aufgemacht und da filmt eigentlich
einer einfach nur den Straßenverkehr, nichts. Und auf einmal klatscht einer auf die Straße,
der ist vom Hochhaus gesprungen und der zerspringt halt komplett, der Typ, oder die, ich weiß
es nicht, da ist nichts mehr da gewesen. Der filmt den Straßenverkehr und den Gehweg und
auf einmal macht es wirklich wie so eine Melone, wie so eine Melone und ich habe es erst nicht
gecheckt, ich habe es erst nicht gecheckt, was passiert, also ich habe es schon gecheckt,
aber erstmal habe ich gedacht, das ist doch fake, das war wirklich eine Kameraaufnahme
von einem Platz, wo sich halt einer gerade vom Hochhaus gestürzt hat. Und da habe ich
mir gedacht, ok, weißt du was Max, du musst dir nicht mehr jeden Scheiß angucken. Wozu?
Dass du dann irgendwann noch einen Dachschaden kriegst davon oder, dass du irgendwann kotzen
musst nochmal oder was weiß ich, warum auch immer. Seitdem habe ich mir gedacht, ne, guck
ich, wenn ich im Vorfeld schon weiß, es ist so absolut abartiges Zeug, dann gucke ich
mir das gar nicht mehr an. Oder ansonsten, wenn es einfach nur quasi Fake Zeug ist in
dem Film und die Filme sonst keinen anderen Schauwert haben, finde ich die auch extrem
langweilig. Aber jetzt gucken wir erstmal das Video fertig an.
Nicht tricksen. Es wird nicht überlegt, wie können wir das faken als realistisch ist.
Aber warum langweile ich euch mit Filmen? Nun, Videospiele haben ein Problem mit dieser
Form von Gewaltherstellung, denn anders als bei Filmen muss man nicht tricksen. Es wird
nicht überlegt, wie können wir das faken, weil man muss einfach nichts faken, man muss
nachmachen. Und genau jetzt kommen wir zum Problem. In jeglicher Form von Kunst sind
Referenzen normal. Ein Zeichner mag sich bestimmte Fotos ansehen, um eine Pose richtig
einzufangen oder schaut sich an, wie das Licht durch Glas bricht. Jemand, der Modelleisenbahnen
baut, wird sich echte Landschaften ansehen und wie genau Eisenbahnschienen verlegt werden,
um jedes Detail einzufangen. Videospiele sind in der Form besonders, da sie so ziemlich
alles abdecken. Und natürlich werden auch dafür Referenzen genutzt, also für Landschaften,
Objekte, Menschen, die Haut eines Menschen, die Wunden an einer Haut, das Aufschützen
von Haut, das Abtrennen von Haut. Auch dafür brauchen die Grafiker Referenzen, denn eine
Explosion lässt Figuren in Spielen nicht mehr einfach durch die Gegend fliegen wie
noch auf dem N64. Sie reißen Gliedmassen ab oder sprengen den Körper komplett auseinander.
Und ich war eine lange Zeit voll dafür, habe nie wirklich darüber nachgedacht. Ich mein,
komm, es ist doch nur ein Spiel und solche Details sind doch irgendwo beeindruckend,
genau wie in Filmen. Bis mir dann klar gemacht wurde, dass es ja nur so aussieht, weil ein
Mensch in einer Videospielfirma die Grafiken dafür erstellen muss. Da hab ich mir noch
nie Gedanken drüber gemacht, ganz ehrlich. Deswegen hab ich das jetzt auch am Anfang
erzählt mit irgendwelchen eklichen Videos. Jetzt überlegt euch mal, ihr arbeitet in
so einer Firma und müsst euch den ganzen Tag angucken, wie Leuten der Kopf platzt.
In echt. Wie echt Leuten der Kopf platzt. Ähm, damit ihr das möglichst realistisch
im Game machen könnt. Das ist wahrscheinlich auf Dauer nicht so schön.
Leute, dass jemand rausfinden musste, wie sich Haut zum Beispiel beim Aufschlitzen
mit einem Messer verhält oder wie Körperteile richtig abgetrennt werden. Und damit diese
Menschen das halt so akkurat hinbekommen, brauchen sie eben genau das, was man in der
Kunst immer verwendet. Referenzen. Um das hier festzuhalten, damit wir als Spieler einen
brutalen Spaß haben, müssen andere sich Referenzen angucken.
Ja, Whitebird. Äh, da kann ich was erzählen. Ähm, ich kenn jemand, der arbeitet bei einer
Erotikplattform, nennen wir das Ganze mal so, ja. Also das ist da, da gibt's Mädels
mit Webcam. Die vermieten allerdings auch Räume. Also die vermieten, dort können sich
keine Mädels anmelden jetzt irgendwie, die dann vermieten oder so. Die vermieten quasi
Räume, die haben Webcam-Programme und sowas. Und dort können zum Beispiel auch User quasi
mit den Models interagieren. Von Private Chat bis zu irgendwelchen Spielchen, selbst wenn
sie offline sind, äh, irgendwelche Dominierungsspielchen, was auch immer, ja. So. Und der hat erzählt,
die müssen sich angucken, was die Leute schicken und hochladen. Also vor allem, was die Leute
halt auch an die Models schicken. Alter. Der hat gemeint, da konnte sich das nicht
lange geben. Der konnte sich das nicht lange geben. Da ist so hochgradig abartiges Zeug
dabei, was die Leute da hochladen. Und sie müssen das allein schon aus Jugendschutzgründen
bzw. halt aus, äh, sag was ich, die müssen gucken, dass die Mädels über 18 sind und
dass da sonst nichts Illegales geschert wird, ja. Also das hat schon einen Grund, warum
die sich das angucken müssen. Und er meinte halt auch, das ist so abartig. Und nachdem
er da eine Weile gearbeitet hat, er kennt jetzt alle Abkürzungen. Also sprich, es sagt
ja keiner, es sagt ja keiner, ich suche jemanden, der mich ankackt. Das hat dann, das hat dann
spezielle Abkürzungen. Und er meinte, er kennt jetzt alle Abkürzungen und weiß quasi
schon, was auf einen zukommt, wenn er das nur hört. Das ist echt, ja. Und die müssen
halt auch da alles sichten, was so wieder den Models geschickt wird, was die Models
hochladen bzw. was da halt ausgetauscht wird, dann schon aus Jugendschutzgründen und halt
auch aus Gesetzesgründen, dass da nichts Illegales hochgeladen wird. Und der Mann,
der kann das nicht lang machen. Also, das hältst du nicht aus. So. Und das ist ja da,
das ist ja da ähnlich, ja, wenn du dir den ganzen Kack angucken musst. Game Age Queue,
zwei Monate lang, schon Stonks, richtig Big Brain Stonks.
Es war geplant, dass jemand, der die Zähne aufnimmt, wie halt die Figur im Spiel um sein
Leben battelt, kurz vor der Hängung. Die eigentliche Hängung hingegen musste per Hand
animiert werden, also wie ein Körper sich halt dann physikalisch korrekt bewegt, wenn
er am Hals, in der Luft stranguliert wird. Young Blood hatte sich einen ganzen Tag lang
Aufzeichnungen von echten Hängungen angesehen, damit er diesen Job ausführen konnte. Und
er sagt selbst, dass es ihn schon beeinflusst hatte. So sehr, dass er es zwar trocken als
sein Job ansehen wollte, die Bilder von den Hängungen, die er sich aber ganze Zeit angesehen
hatte, geht auch nicht mehr aus seinem Kopf bekam. In der Zeit, in der er diese Animation
erstellen musste, war er emotional komplett runtergefahren, hatte nicht mal mehr mit seinen
Arbeitskollegen oder gar seiner Frau wirklich gesprochen. Nachdem die Animation fertig war,
normalisierte es sich wieder, jedoch hat es ihn für immer stumpfer gemacht gegenüber
solchen Animationen. Ein synonymer Entwickler, der an Mortal Kombat 11 gearbeitet hatte,
berichtet,
Es gibt ja da nur zwei Varianten. Entweder du drehst mit der Zeit durch, oder du bist
weniger empfindlich. Das sind so die zwei Sachen, die passieren können. Oder, oder,
oder, oder du hast es nicht mehr alle und findest geil. Das gibt es natürlich auch,
das darf man nicht vergessen. Die 1-2% der Leute gibt es ja immer. Und davon auch nicht
vergessen. Easykiller sagt, wieso müssen das realistisch sein? Weil man das wahrscheinlich
so festgelegt hat. Man sagt, okay, wir möchten das spielen, wir haben einen realistischen
Grafikstil, wir möchten, dass die Kampfszenen möglichst realistisch sind, die Animationen
möglichst realistisch sind. Da hat einer gesagt, okay, wir wollen, dass das auch möglichst
realistisch ist, dass es nicht irgendwie out of place wirkt.
Wie es für ihn war, Gewalt in dem Detail.
Trägt er letztendlich für einen Spieler auch zur Atmosphäre bei, wenn die Story eben
halt auch realistisch macht, dass dann auch das, was passiert, realistisch aussieht.
Wie er zu realisieren. Seine Arbeit am Spiel resultierte letztendlich zu einer posttraumatischen
Belastungsstörung. Er hatte extrem gewalttätige und detaillierte Träume, die so heftig waren,
dass er nicht mal mehr schlafen wollte und oft Tage am Stück wach war. Einfach nur,
damit er nicht mehr schlafen musste. Er berichtet davon, dass, wenn man im Office rumgelaufen
ist, halt solche Sachen sieht, wie einer sich Hengungen ansieht, ein anderer schaut sich
Bilder von Mordopfern an und jemand anderes sieht sich an, wie eine Kuh gerade geschlachtet
wird. Er meinte auch, dass es immer unheimlich war, wenn neu...
Captain Falcon, man kann Filme nicht unbedingt als Vorlage nehmen, weil es in Filmen halt
nicht realistisch ist. Weil es in Filmen wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil total übertrieben ist oder
halt, wie er am Anfang gesagt hat, möglichst gut gefaked wird. Und die wollen halt wissen,
wie sieht es wirklich aus. Ich meine, wenn du was realistisch machen willst, was ist besser?
Du guckst dir die Realität an oder du guckst dir die interpretierte Realität von jemand
anderem an, der sich vielleicht mal, wenn der Glück hat, das im Original angeguckt hat?
Übrigens, es ist ein super Thema für ein Video von ihm. Also, ich habe mir da noch
nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
...neue Kollegen am Spiel gearbeitet haben und ebenfalls langsam stumpf dem gegenüber
wurden. Alex Hudson, ein Game Director, der in Spielen arbeitete wie Assassin's Creed
3 und Far Cry 4, meint, dass je höher der Realismus wird, desto mehr Gefahr gibt es.
Es geht halt darum, wie genau und echt die Game Assets langsam werden. Paar seiner Freunde
zum Beispiel arbeiteten an Outlast und haben gescherzt, wie es nicht gerade ihr Lieblingsjob
war.
Charles Mack sagt, wie ist es mit 3D-Animationsfilmen? Also, ich kenne keinen 3D-Animationsfilm,
wo Leute realistisch geköpft werden. Sollte das der Fall sein und jemand möchte das erstellen,
dann ist es genau das gleiche Problem.
...zu investieren, um tote Babys zu modellieren. Wir als Spieler werden das nicht haben. Wir
werden halt nicht wirklich psychisch belastet, wenn wir ein Spiel spielen mit einem hohen
Gewaltgrad. Wenn du dich aber als Entwickler Tage, Wochen, gar Monate mit dieser Thematik
beschäftigen musst, sieht es einfach anders aus. Ein weiterer Entwickler, der an Mortal
Kombat 11 arbeitete, meinte, dass, wenn er seinen Hund ansieht, nicht mehr wirklich den
Hund sieht, sondern seine ganzen Innereien. Er konnte ihn nicht mehr ansehen, ohne sich
seine Eingeweide vorzustellen, weil das sein Job war und man nicht wissen will, was er
sich alles an Referenzmaterial einziehen musste.
Vic De Leon arbeitete an Halo 3, speziell an dem Level, wo alles von der Flotte infiziert
ist. Um sich auf das Level vorzubereiten, hatte er zwei Wochen lang Referenzmaterial
zusammengesammelt. Biologischer Kram, wissenschaftlicher Kram, sehr viel ekliger Kram. Das Team wollte
lange, dünne, organische Gänge haben und deswegen wurden sich Videos angesehen von
Koloskopiedurchführungen, weil das Wandern durch den Dickdarm eine wichtige Inspiration
war für die Umgebung, da man sich führen sollte, als wenn man irgendwo...
Ach das, deswegen sieht das so aus wie ein Darm, weil das Vorbild auch ein Darm gewesen
ist. Jetzt leuchtet das auch ein.
Um das Ganze mehr Detail zu geben, hatte er sich Bilder angesehen von Tumoren und Verletzungen.
Er hat es sich angesehen und sich überlegt, was man in Spiel übernehmen könnte. Und
obwohl er eine hohe Toleranzgrenze hat für solche Sachen, wurde ihm hin und wieder einfach
nur kotzübel. Und auch er, wie halt sehr viele andere, berichtet davon, dass diese Bilder
ihn im normalen Alltag verfolgt haben. Es ging so weit, dass seine Kollegen...
Ja, muss ja so sein. Überlegt euch mal, ihr macht wirklich den ganzen Tag eine Sache.
Sei es jetzt, ihr spielt ein Spiel den ganzen Tag, ihr programmiert den ganzen Tag an irgendwas,
ihr macht irgendwas den ganzen Tag. Wer hatte das noch nicht, dass er nachts genau
von dem gleichen Scheiß träumt? Wenn ich jetzt morgens aufstehe, Passive Exile oder
so anschmeiße und den ganzen Tag im Kreis grinde oder ein MMO-Spiel und den ganzen Tag
dort irgendwas mache, dann träume ich da auch nachts davon. Ich meine, ich habe öfters,
ich habe den ganzen Tag nichts anderes gemacht. Und dann stellt euch mal vor, ihr guckt euch
den ganzen Tag Darmspiegelungen an. Also als Nicht-Urologe oder, oder wer macht das überhaupt?
Keine Ahnung. Also als, ne? Dann findet ihr wahrscheinlich das auch kacke, wenn ihr da
nachts von Darmspiegelungen träumt. Die haben echt einen Scheißjob. Also wer YouTube und
Facebook und andere, und wisst ihr was ich mir noch, was ich mir fast noch schlimmer
vorstelle, anders, anders gelagert, vielleicht, als YouTube und Facebook, ist Leute, die bei
Pornhub und solchen Sachen die Uploads kontrollieren. Ich will nicht wissen, was da für fertiges
Zeug hochgeladen wird teilweise. Ich meine, du kannst ja auf Pornhub mehr oder weniger
alles hochladen, solange es halt legal ist. Aber ich wette mit euch, da laden so viele
Leute Zeug hoch, was einfach nur abartig ist und irgendjemand muss den Scheißprobe gucken.
Und auch wenn wir das in unserer Gesellschaft als Teeheehee ansehen, habe ich einen Kollegen,
der sehr lange für eine Porno-Webseite den User-Content crawlen musste, damit ich dann
nicht... Hä? Ich finde, ich finde das cool. Ich finde das cool, ne? Ich habe das Video
ja schon geguckt. Ich finde das cool, dass der auch jemand kennt und dass sich die Erfahrungen
da decken. Das ist illegal, das hochgeladen wird und das stumpft halt ab, macht einen
regelrecht Matsch. Bei Videospielen ist eben das Ding, dass man sich nicht nur ansehen
muss, sondern auch noch irgendwo umsetzen, halt grafisch. Wir kennen den gleich, ne, das
glaube ich nicht. Oder vielleicht, keine Ahnung. Aber eher nicht. Diskutiert, jede
Gewaltanimation wird Frame für Frame durchgekaut und analysiert, um sie zu verbessern. Und
das alles nur für brutalen Spaß für die Spieler oder Schockmomente bei Spielen, die sich
selbst zu ernst nehmen. Und ich weiß, dass einige das echt nicht hören können, dass
man dann krampfhaft versucht, dagegen zu argumentieren. Alla, dann sind die halt falsch in ihrem Job,
wenn die das nicht abkönnen. Und hier ist wohl Empathie das Stichwort. Also, das ist
ja das, was ich gerade auch als Beispiel gemeint habe, die Leute, die sich Pornhubprobe angucken.
Ich stelle mir das noch schlimmer vor. Den einen, den ich kenne, wie gesagt, das ist
ja eher eine Seite, wo die Leute mit den Models halt chatten privat und dort halt auch den
Models Dinger schicken und solche Sachen. Aber klar, da ist halt auch viel abartiges
Zeugs dabei. Also das ist nicht so eine Public-Porn-Seite, wie Pornhub, sondern eher so eine Camgirl-Seite,
wo er gearbeitet hat. Und ja, muss auch viel abartiges gewesen sein.
Das ist einem schwerfältig, sich reinzuversetzen, wie andere Menschen sich bei bestimmten Dingen
fühlen. Wenn man es also nicht nachempfinden kann, warum das für Menschen nicht gut ist,
sich ständig solch Referenzmaterial angucken zu müssen, da soll sich einfach mal eine Stunde
lang Videos von einem Schlachthof angucken. Nicht nur kann man es dann sicherlich nachempfinden.
Ich kann sofort verstehen, wenn da einer Veganer wird oder Vegetarier, wenn er sich das angeguckt
hat. Nein, wir hätten dann sicher auch noch einen vegan lebenden Menschen mehr. Und wir
sind durch. Ein sehr wichtiges Thema, bei dem ich selbst noch nicht wirklich Antworten habe,
aber ich muss extrem häufig darüber nachdenken. Das ist schon teilweise echt abartig, was
da auch abgeht. Gibt es jetzt dieses Video? Wie seht ihr das Ganze? Habt ihr jemals darüber
nachgedacht und seht ihr es jetzt ein wenig anders? Wie immer lade ich zur Diskussion
in den Kommentaren ein. Kleine wichtige Information, das nächste Technikvideo handelt von Spongebob
Rehydrated. Wer dazu eine Frage einsenden möchte, folgt mir am besten auf Twitter,
da will ich dir dazu aufrufen. Also, wie gesagt, kann ich nur empfehlen euch zu abonnieren,
das macht jede Menge gute Videos. Wenn man sich zum Beispiel anguckt, was er sonst noch
so hat in letzter Zeit. Manchmal flamet er ein bisschen Nintendo, er macht viel Technikvideos
über verschiedene, vor allem ältere Games. Also, wie gesagt, kann ich echt nur empfehlen.
Weil er jetzt gerade gesagt hat, wenn sich Leute mal Videos von einem Schlachthof angucken,
da werden sie veganer, so sinngemäß, ist mir eine Sache eingefallen, wo ich letztens
etwas drüber gesehen habe, dass Leute Tierrettungsvideos auf YouTube machen und vorher quasi die Tiere
eingesperrt haben, die sie retten können, weil das Views macht. Das fand ich auch echt
abartig. Also sprich, da gibt es dann ein Video, keine Ahnung, Katze in ein Rohr gefallen
und wir retten Katze aus einem Rohr. In Wirklichkeit haben sie die Katze vorher in das Rohr gesteckt
und da 4 Stunden drin stecken lassen, dass die ordentlich anfängt zu schreien und dann
retten sie die im Video. So, und das ist auch ein komplettes Undinger. Ja, so gefakte Tierrettung
in die Richtung, ja. iGamble0 sagt, ich finde, nee, Moment, CrashFluffy sagt, ich dachte,
es müssten werden Experten zur Rate gezogen. Naja, schon, aber die Experten können, also
ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es so ist. Die Experten, die können vielleicht anatomisch
Sachen erklären, ja, aber letztendlich, wenn du einen hast, der das Ganze modellieren muss,
animieren muss, Konzeptbilder, was auch immer erstellen muss, das bringt ihm ja nichts, wenn
er an den Experten zur Rate zieht, der muss das ja sehen, dass er das malen kann oder
dass er das modellieren kann oder dass er das animieren kann. Da reicht der an den Experten
nicht für, weil ein Experte kann ja wohl schlecht das Modellieren übernehmen. Was
ein Experte machen kann, ist am Ende zu sagen, ok, man hat es halbwegs realistisch getroffen.
iGamble0 sagt, ich finde, die Spiele müssten gar nicht so realistisch, sag ich mal kurz
den Chat auf hier, ich finde, die Spiele müssen gar nicht so realistisch sein, mir würde
das schon wie bei Armour oder Rainbow Six reichen, wo einfach rote Flecken auftauchen.
Naja, das ist halt eine Sache, die man als Entwickler oder in irgendeinem Anforderungen-Katalog,
was auch immer definiert hat, was das Ganze sein soll oder Visionen oder wie hat, sagt
ich mal, diese Eigenschaften soll unser Produkt haben und letztendlich ist es ja auch so, dass
es eine gewisse Überzeugungssache ist auch für die Spieler. Wenn man sagt, ok, wir machen
halt hier ein besonders realistisches Game, dann erwarten die Spieler halt auch, dass
es auch realistisch ist oder wir machen ein Game, was quasi eine ernste Story hat, sich
an der Realität orientiert und ich glaube, in Call of Duty erwartet das keiner, da erwartet
man das eher wie in einem Film, over the top, aber bei sowas wie The Last of Us, da würde
ich jetzt nicht erwarten, dass wenn ich einem mit der Shotgun irgendwie in den Kopf schieße,
dass dann Blümchen kommen oder so. Klar, man könnte auch sagen, ok, warum kippt er
nicht einfach nur um? Das sind halt Sachen, die sich da die Entwickler selbst auferlegt
haben, wie realistisch sie das machen wollen. Und gerade bei Last of Us 2 ist es ja was,
wo sie halt auch zeigen wollen, gerade, also wie gesagt, ich habe mir ja ein Let's Play
angeguckt, ich spoilere auch nicht, wo sie ja gerade zeigen wollen Gewalt und Rache und
sonst was, was mit den Leuten passiert, was ich für, also das Let's Play, was ich mir
angeguckt habe und wie sich The Last of Us 2 entwickelt, hat mir persönlich nicht so
zugesagt. Also ich denke, man hätte da eine schönere Story machen können, aber gut,
das ist, ja, das müssen die wissen. Ist dein Dark Reader im Chat Pop-Up an? Ja. Guck mal,
das kann sich gar nicht entscheiden, das kann sich gar nicht entscheiden, was hier, was
es hier machen soll, Alter. Jetzt ist der Dark Reader aus. Tribulon sagt, die Leaks haben
ihm 70€ gespart. Ja, ich werde es mir auch nicht kaufen, also mir hat The Last of Us
2 überhaupt, das Let's Play, was ich mir da angeguckt habe, absolut nicht zugesagt,
also und wenn man sich die Bewertung anguckt, ich sage ja meistens, die Leute übertreiben
es und ob man einem Spiel, was, ja, ob man dem jetzt 3 Sterne geben muss von 10, da habe
ich so meine Zweifel dran, aber ich kann es verstehen, dass die meisten Leute halt nach
so langer Wartezeit echt enttäuscht sind, wie sich die Story entwickelt und vor allem,
dass so viele unrelevante Charaktere auf einmal Relevanz haben. So, aber wie gesagt, ich will
da nicht zu viel spoilern jetzt. Wie gefällt dir PoE bis jetzt so? Na ja, wie gesagt,
ich habe den Account seit 2013, das Spiel ist immer noch top. Ich habe heute Morgen
mal ein bisschen Gear abgecreated und jetzt auf meine endgültige, mein endgültiges Cars
Setup umgestellt. So, was haben wir sonst noch hier schönes? 10 Mythen über das Darknet,
das gucken wir uns jetzt noch an. Über das Internet, da muss ich immer, kennt ihr noch
ein Dings? Arche Internets oder wie das hieß? Oder Arche, wie hieß das denn? Hieß das nicht
Arche Internets? Oder so ähnlich war, wie hieß das? Ja, Arche im Netz, Arche Internets,
die Trollplattform, ja ja, was halt von vorne bis hinten getrollt war, wo viele drauf angesprochen
sind. Es heißt ja auch nicht Internet surfen, sondern Internet stehsegeln, wissen wir ja
alle. Was, da ist das Java? Sehe ich das richtig? Ist das Java? Nein, ist das Java? Man erkennt
es nicht, das ist irgendein Jason Dings, nee. Ja, das hier ist Java, das ist auf jeden Fall
Java hier, Cradle, Android. Ernst nehmen sollte. Der erste Mythos beginnt direkt mit der Begrifflichkeit
Darknet und ihrer Einordnung. Viele denken, dass mit dem Deepweb, von dem oft die Rede
ist, gleichzeitig auch das Darknet gemeint ist. Dem ist aber keineswegs so. Keineswegs
Leute. Wie du aus meinem Video zwischen dem Deepweb und dem Darknet weißt, ist das Darknet
eine Teilmenge des Deepwebs und macht weniger als 1% des gesamten Internets aus, während
man das Deepweb ca. 98% bildet. Wenn man das Deepweb meint, dann handelt es sich dabei
nicht... Oh jetzt ist Big Brain Talk angesagt, Alter. Das Darknet und umgekehrt. Viele behaupten,
dass es schwierig sei, ins Darknet zu kommen. Das ist aber falsch. Tor Browser auf und
gut ist. Ja, genau. Also schwer ist es über besten Willen nicht. Die Frage ist ja, was
will man da? Nö. Wenn du da nichts Illegales machst, ist es auch nicht illegal. Du solltest
halt vielleicht davon absehen, irgendwelche Sachen zu kaufen, die man nicht kaufen darf,
oder vielleicht Sachen zu verkaufen, die man nicht verkaufen darf, oder die man nicht
machen darf.
In sich ist nicht illegal. Überhaupt sprechen wir beim Darknet eigentlich primär von Seiten,
die nur über den Tor Browser erreichbar sind, die man nicht über klassische Suchmaschinen
finden kann und auf denen zum Beispiel Hidden Services angeboten werden. Auch ein Hidden
Service ist erstmal nicht illegal. Selbst Facebook bietet einen Hidden Service an, der
es den Nutzern des Tor Browsers erleichtern soll, Facebook zu nutzen. Noch dazu später
mehr. Man darf aber natürlich nicht verschweigen. Matt, du hast recht, aber das hat er aber
auch nicht gesagt. Er hat mir gesagt, man benutzt den Tor Browser dafür. Dass man jetzt
das Ziel hätte, das Darkweb zu betreiben, ist ja Blödsinn. Tor ist ein Anonymisierungstool,
fertig aus.
Hierzu zählen zum Beispiel Plattformen, auf denen man Drogen und Waffen kaufen kann.
Doch auch hier geht es, dass der Besuch an sich erstmal nicht illegal ist. Erst der Kauf
von Waffen oder die Beauftragung von Hackern werden als Straftat angesehen. Die genaue
Gesetzeslage hängt von dem, wie man es sagt. Wir müssen keine Hacker beauftragen. Wir
hacken selbst.
In Korea ist alleine die Nutzung des Tor Browsers schon illegal. Das Darknet macht weniger als
1% des gesamten Internets aus. Mit dem normalen Internet meint man oft das Surface Web, das
nur etwa 2% ausmacht. Dementsprechend ist das Darknet immer noch viel kleiner als
das Surface Web.
Warum kommt vermutlich dadurch zustande, dass für viele das Deep Web und das Darknet dasselbe
ist. Du weißt es aber mittlerweile besser. Dadurch, dass viele denken, das Darknet sei
illegal, wird oft behauptet, dass sich im Darknet nur Kriminelle herumtreiben. Wie du
mittlerweile weißt, ist das Darknet an sich keineswegs illegal und somit ist diese Behauptung
auch falsch. Es treiben sich im Darknet natürlich auch Kriminelle herum, doch die absoluten
Zahlen dürften im Rest des Internets weitaus höher sein, wenn man zum Beispiel an die
Skandale um solche Media Plattformen oder diverse Scamming Webseiten denkt. Zudem ist
für viele politisch Verfolgte das Darknet eine der wenigen Möglichkeiten nun geschützt
mit anderen zu kommunizieren. Das hat schon einen Grund, weshalb der Tor Browser in Nord
Korea verboten ist.
Wusstet ihr, dass Nord Korea daran schuld ist? Ich finde das Bild echt gut gemacht.
Okay. Chat findet es nicht lustig, ich finde es lustig. Vor allem die Falte auf der Stirn,
die sieht auch noch aus wie ein Mund, wenn man nicht richtig hinguckt. Also das haben
sie echt gut gemacht. Hat gedauert. Nord Korea ist schuld. True. Lul weh.
Der Sinn dieses Services ist natürlich fragwürdig, denn was bringt die Nutzung von Facebook über
Tor, wenn man sich am Ende doch anmelden muss und damit zeigt, wer man ist. Dadurch gibst
du Facebook lediglich noch mehr Informationen, denn dadurch wissen sie, dass du den Tor Browser
verwendest und können dieses Wissen wiederum dazu nutzen, um dir zum Beispiel Werbung für
spezielle Security-Lösungen anzuzeigen. Hidden Services sind also sehr wohl in der
Lage, Informationen über dich einzuholen, wenn du es eben zulässt. Aber auch wenn du
es nicht bewusst zulässt, könnte Chat Software auf dein Rechner gelangen, die es Hackern
ermöglicht, deine realen Standortdaten zu ermitteln.
Ja, das habe ich in meinem VPN-Video zum Beispiel auch schon erzählt. Es hat überhaupt keinen
Sinn, wenn man alles über seinen VPN macht, aber letztendlich auf dem Server selbst, wo
man am Ende rauskommt, dann eingibt, ich will eine Pizza bestellen, hier Frankfurt 60329
und so was.
Du solltest also unbedingt aufpassen, was du dir im Darknet herunterlädst, ob du die
Ausführung von Skripten zulässt und so weiter. Das Gerücht, alle Hidden Services seien illegal,
ist, wenn du Hidden Services von Facebook bereits aus der Welt geschaffen. Wir haben im Netzwerkpraktikum
damals auch einen Hidden Service implementiert, um uns mit der Funktionsweise des Tor Netzwerks
bzw. Only-Rooting-Protokolls vertraut zu machen. Wenn alle Hidden Services illegal wären, wäre
auch unser Hidden Service illegal gewesen, was die Uni wiederum zum Anstift einer Straftat
gemacht hat.
Ich hätte aber gar nichts dagegen, wenn Facebook illegal ist.
Wenn sich eine Uni so etwas natürlich nicht erlaubt ist, klar, um es noch einmal zu sagen,
nicht alle Hidden Services sind illegal. Es gibt aber selbstverständlich auch illegale
Hidden Services, doch die erkennt man schon, wenn man seinen gesunden Menschenverstand
einschaltet. Oder denkst du, dass ein Marktplatz, auf dem man gestohlene Kreditkarteninformationen
kaufen kann, legal ist?
Na klar.
Vermutlich nicht.
Apropos kaufen.
Na klar, was soll das sonst sein? Muss doch legal sein.
Dass man im Darknet alles kaufen könne, hält sich bis heute. Von Auftragskillern über
Drogen bis hin zu Hackerdienstleistungen. Das Problem ist, dass man einiges davon in
der Theorie zumindest tatsächlich kaufen kann, wie etwa Drogen und Waffen. Allerdings ist
damit eine gewisse Unsicherheit verbunden, denn ein Merkmal eines Hidden Services ist,
dass der Käufer nicht weiß, bei wem er kauft und der Verkäufer nicht weiß, wem er etwas
verkauft. Somit sind Betrügereien doch eigentlich schon vorprogrammiert. Wenn man nicht weiß,
bei wem man etwas kauft, kann man diese Person im Nachhinein nur schwer verklagen. Insbesondere
wenn man sich etwas Illegales besorgen möchte. Stell dir mal vor, du gehst zur Polizei und
sagst, ich habe mir hier eine Waffe im Darknet gekauft und die entsprechende Person, die meldet
sich einfach nicht mehr. Können wir da irgendwas machen? Ziemlich witzige Gedanke. Das wissen
natürlich auch die Verkäufer. Das Einkaufen im Darknet ist immer mit einem gewissen Risiko
verbunden und sollte so gut es geht vermieden werden. Zu denen gibt es bestimmte Dinge von
dem, was man gibt. Nee, also eigentlich müsste man das ja dann anders machen. Da kauft sich
dann jemand im Darknet eine Waffe und wenn die nicht richtig funktioniert, dann kauft
er sich den Auftragskiller und setzt ihn auf den Waffenverkäufer an. Wenn schon, muss man
das auch komplett alles im Darknet abwickeln dann. Was, wenn ihn dann der Killer abzieht?
Du meinst, wenn der Killer dich dann auch scammt, nee, dann musst du den nächsten Killer nehmen
und auf die Killer ansetzen. Gibt da wohl genug Angebote? Und richtig abgedreht wird
es dann, wenn der zweite Killer, um den ersten Killer zu killen, der das nicht geschafft
hat, wiederum Waffen kauft beim ersten Waffenhändler und auch eine gescampte Waffe bekommt.
Was war das nochmal? War das diese Geschichte, wo irgendwelche Leute umgebracht werden mit
Kamera oder sowas? Wo dann ergeblich, wo es fragwürdig ist, ob es da also überhaupt
vielmals gegeben hat? Ja, genau, genau, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, ja. Ergesslich.
beziehungsweise die Übertragung alles andere als flüssig läuft. Und selbst wenn es sie geben sollte,
wird nicht jeder an solchen Livestreams einfach teilnehmen können, da man hierfür eine gesonderte
Einladung bräuchte. Der ökonomische Nutzen ist ohnehin fraglich, weshalb man dafür aktiv
Geld ausgeben müsste und entsprechende Kontakte bräuchte. Du brauchst also keine Angst haben,
dass du zufällig über so etwas stolperst. Dennoch empfehle ich dir nicht aktiv nach solchen
Inhalten zu suchen, da du damit nur die Produzenten, sollte es sie geben, in ihrem kriminellen Treiben
unterstützt und wahrscheinlich mit offenen Armen eine Scam hineinläufst. Denn alles, was irgendwie
populär ist und viel geklickt wird, dient Scammern als Grundlage dafür, um neue Opfer zu fangen.
Vielen Dank fürs zusehen. Solltest du weitere Fragen haben, kannst du sie gerne unten in den Kommentaren
oder auf meiner Fragenplattform informatikstudium.net posten. Informatikstudium.net. So, so.
So Leute, wir müssen uns jetzt noch eine Runde. Livestreams sind durchaus möglich im Tornades
aber eher mit Low-Quality und Großmille. Ja klar, du kannst, natürlich kannst du irgendwelche
Motion-JPEG-Dinger machen oder so, ja. Aber das, was man heutzutage so unter normalem Livestream
versteht, kriegst du da bei der Bandbreite nicht drüber. Vor allem hast du ja oftmals auch bei
Livestream das Problem, dass es da drauf ankommt, dass die Sache halbwegs in normaler Zeit ankommt.
Aber was bringt es dir, wenn du Teile vom letzten Frame bekommst, nachdem schon der aktuelle Frame
da ist und sowas. Kann man GIFs streamen? Ne. Ich glaube GIFs kann man nicht streamen, weil du von Anfang an wissen musst,
wie lang das GIF ist und ich glaube auch nicht, dass GIFs einzelne Frames encoded sind. Wobei
animiertes GIFs sind wahrscheinlich einzelne Bill. Keine Ahnung, ob man nicht theoretisch mit
Trig17 GIFs streamen könnte, aber ich glaube nicht, dass man GIFs streamen kann. Ja, Motion-JPEG
hat schlechte Kompression, das ist richtig, aber Motion-JPEG ist halt sehr robust für Streams,
aus dem Grund, weil es halt immer einzelne Bilder gibt. Da gibt es kein Diff, keine Keyframes,
kein sonst was. Da gibt es einfach JPEG-Bild, das Sekunde wieder, JPEG-Bild, JPEG-Bild, JPEG-Bild.
HLS Stream 480p größere Stream könnte wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren, könnte auch funktionieren.
Da muss halt ordentliche Bufferlänge sein, so irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 30 Sekunden oder 45
Sekunden oder so. Es könnte auch funktionieren, müsste man mal ausprobieren. Aber eigentlich
habe ich gar keinen Bock, das auszuprobieren. Sind Timeout-Umfragen bei den Wooplus-Pumpen,
eigentlich die sind neue, ja. Allerdings, das stellt nur eine Anfrage und ein Mod muss die dann
bearbeiten. Timeout könnte sein, dass das sogar funktioniert, ohne dass der Mod das machen muss.
Da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher. Aber der Sebaro ist halt immer so schnell, der macht das alles so
instant. Alles manuell, na toll. Tolles Feature Twitch, wenn es doch nicht mal automatisch
funktioniert. Okay, wir gucken jetzt Battlefield-Topplays an. Brauchen noch ein bisschen was zum
entspannen. Der Bane-Bubbo. What? Was gibt das, wenn es fertig ist?
Hä? Der lockt den jetzt übers C4 drüber, oder? Der lockt den jetzt übers C4,
oder was macht der jetzt? Der lockt den übers C4 und springt das C4 in die Luft.
Das kann aber durchaus gefaked sein. Das kann durchaus gefaked sein, also. Also,
mein erstes passiert ja auf dem Server sonst nicht allzu viel.
Aber trotzdem geil, finde ich cool. Selbst wenn es Setup ist. Warum nicht?
Die fliegen auch noch geradeaus, hä? Bam. Pro-Ham.
E, PS4. Oh, sieht das scheiße aus. Woodface. Ist das mal ein PS4-Grafix. Also, wenn das
jetzt hintert, ist das pures Glück. Ja, das ist einfach. Also, diese Wahrscheinlichkeit
hätten die mal vorher in dem Wahrscheinlichkeitsvideo berechnen sollen. Predicted-Skill. Ja, klar,
ist klar, Chat. Da werden sie geschneibert. Boah. Hier ist er alle geil headshotted.
Okay, es schießt auch keiner zurück, aber da sind wir ja schon gewohnt.
Oh, No-Scope. Ah. Oh, der hätte noch mehr gehen können.
Also, da muss ich eben mal widersprechen. Das ist nicht, was what sniping is about. Sich
irgendwann Arsch der Welt zu setzen in Battlefield und äh. Moment, man kann in Battlefield Scopes
switchen. Kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern, als es in Battlefield 4 ging.
Die besten Sniper-Clips sind aggressive in your face.
Forlateral. Nee, doch nicht. Ist das die Pickup-Sniper? Nee, nee, das ist nicht die Pickup-Sniper,
oder? Oh, we're in your face.
Die Pickup ist ja auch so Semi-Auto. Warum one-shotted er die Gegner eigentlich,
obwohl es kein Headshot ist teilweise. Ah, nice, nice. Ach so, wenn das hardcore ist,
dann ist klar, dass die alle down gehen. G18, OP-Pistole in dem Spiel. Die war in Battlefield
3 auch schon ziemlich OP. Oh, oh. Oh, das war ein nicer Snipe. Das war nur echt mal
ein richtig nicer Snipe. Ich finde, das sind die Sachen, die, äh,
in Battlefield bis Battlefield 4 ausgemacht haben. Das ist halt nicht gescriptet. Das
ist halt richtig geil. Da kommt so ein A10 auf dich zugeflogen, du schießt ihn raus
und dann fliegt das Ding halt so einen Meter über deinen Kopf drüber und crasht dann
da hinten. Absolut nicht gescriptet, ganz normal Dynamik von einem Multiplayer-Match.
Und das ist halt das, was Battlefield für mich mit ausgemacht hat. So, wir haben auch
letztens Battlefield 3 gespielt. Wie in positiver Weise das Spiel anstrengend ist, ist halt
geil. Du bist permanent irgendwie unter Strom in Battlefield 3, aber es passiert ja laufend
auch was Geiles. Und es ist nicht so, nicht so abfuck anstrengend wie Warzone, sondern
einfach nur anstrengend und Spaß macht anstrengend.
Da stehen sie und kriege wieder nichts mit. Ok, warum? Das habe ich mich auf Locker schon
immer gefragt. Warum ist da eine Heizung? Das ist der unsinnigste Ort einen Heizkörper
zu platzieren im gesamten Gebäude. Ja, warum die Gegner nichts machen ist der nächste
Fall. Aber was macht die Heizung hier? Da hättest du hier genauso gut einen 3000 Euro
Klo mit Spülung hinbauen können. Da wäre genauso sinnvoll wie diese Heizung an dieser
Stelle. In solchen Clips sind das immer pepega Gegner, ja klar, mit gutem Gegner geht das
sowas auch nicht. Und dann wird er quickscoped. Und die checken wieder absolut nichts. Was
ist das? Collateral? Nee. Manche Leute aimen schon echt ganz gut. Auch im Battlefield.
Das zu hitten ist eine Ione. Acer? Also ich glaube der letzte Nickname den ich mir irgendwie
mal in einem Game geben würde ist Acer. Sind das Deutsche? Asus, ja Mensch, Asus.
Und denkt mal Leute nicht Aces, Asus. Q-Con ist am Start, ja ganz viele.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, Battlefield 4 hab ich hauptsächlich ACR gespielt. Das
Ding war teilweise echt OP. Keine Ahnung wie das jetzt balansmäßig ist. Ich hab hier
eben nicht gespielt. Und danach kamen noch ein paar Patches. Der Waffensound war auch
so gut in den Battlefield Teilen da. Oh da lassen sie sich wieder wegspringen. Warum
hat er nicht gerätzt? Oh hoffentlich rätzt er noch. Nein, oh jetzt darf ich das Video
wieder nicht zeigen sonst regen sich die Leute auf warum ich Videos promote und nicht gerätzt
wird. Pepehands. Oh das hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert wenn er das überlebt hätte.
Oh Tribulon. Sackt. War das Burst? War die Waffe Burst in dem Spiel? Ey die war Burst,
die war Burst. Achja, steht sogar da. Ich fänd das immer geil in den Videos mit dem Hintergrund
die Leute so aufgeregt klicken hört. AD AD SPAM AD AD SPAM Rheinland Rheinland Rheinland
Rheinland Rheinland Rheinland. AD AD AD AD AD. Gaming ASMR. Chat Fragen lesen consultant
habe ich übersehen
das akrohörnchen
Ich finde daran erkennt man immer leute dieses spiel eine ganze weile spielen wenn die schon aufhören zu schießen bevor der kill kommt
weil die ungefähr genau wissen
wie viel damage man, braucht klar das kann bei der hit detection battlefield auch mal in die hose gehen
Chat fragen ist besser als das ist wahr das ist wohl wahr
vor allem
weil wir ja den haben
das battlefield 4m oder? ja er muss ja muss ja
Ich bin ja der plaufilter
Ja also die spotting geschichte muss ich sagen dass einer der punkte in battlefield also bc2 bf3 bf4
Da muss ich sagen die spotting geschichte war manchmal schon gerade in bett company 2 war spotting hardcore ungefähr
bf3 bf4 ging
Aber es war manchmal schon ein bisschen op also das durch das walker spotte und und auch teilweise nur noch auf gepumpte geschieße
das war eine der wenigen sachen die ich in battlefield
Weiß gar nicht ob es fünf oder oder eins war
prinzipiell ganz gut fand
Hardcore modus nehmen mag ich überhaupt net
Und die zweite ist ein etwas langer clip. Diesmal schauen wir uns die m60 in der support-klasse spielst du
Das ding hat keinen rückstoß oder kann das sein
Das hat keine rückstoß oder das einfach
Rückstoß auf a rate doch das hat einen rückstoß das hat einen rückstoß aber das visier hat keine rückstoß
Nächsten push in to the objectives we skip forward in the clip as he was doing exactly that planning is attack
And for the next minute or so he just dominates on this quite tricky rush map
Es sieht man selten auch immer macht sogar die lege henne
Ja die lege henne höchstpersönlich
Er hat drei gegner gekillt und die lege henne gemacht ich will nicht sagen, dass das schlecht ist
Oh jetzt jetzt kriegt er aus jetzt kriegen sie aufs maul
Ich hätte den schon längst aus der hüfte weggesprayt anstatt ihn zu messern ich hatte Schiss gehabt dass er sich umdreht
Also muss sagen, dass das gegner wegtappen mit der m60 hat er echt drauf und das ist wieder ppega gegner extrem
Und das ist wieder ppega gegner extrem
Der hätte ich noch ein paar kills gegönnen
Messer konter deswegen hätte ich ihn aus der hüfte weggesprayt weil ich hätte schiss gehabt dass er sich umdreht und counter knife war ja
Counter knife war ja easy du musstest in battlefield einfach nur wenn ich einer frontal geneift hat einfach nur ff ff ff du musstest einfach nur ff ff ff
Du musstest doch nicht mal ein gutes timing einfach nur f durch spam und du hast counter knife gekillt
Also überhaupt kein ding incredible a battlefield 5 plays die git warum sollte man battlefield 5 plays sich angucken
Sagen wir das usb no chat oh leute es ist 22 ohr 18
22 18 ich muss pennen ich muss morgen arbeiten
Ja, ja, ja, ich muss leider ich muss leider off
Vielleicht sehen wir uns morgen schon direkt wieder bis denn macht's gut see you. Ah, ja, ja
Ja, ja, ja
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja
Ja,
Ja!
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Untertitel von SWISS TXT